هذا وقد شهدت الاشهر الاخيره عمليات طعن
واطلاق نار استهدفت مستوطنات ومواقع
عسكريه لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في ارجاء
الضفه الغربيه المحتله نستذكر ابرزح في
الرابع عشر من سبتمبر تموز من العام
الجاري قتل جندي اسرائيلي في عمليه اطلاق
نار قرب حاجزي الجلمه شمال الضفه الغربيه
المحتله وفي الثانيه عشر من الشهر ذاته
اصيب ثمانيه اسرائيليين جراء عمليه الطعام
قرب مدينه مذيعين على الطريق بين القدس
وتل ابيب واستشهد منفذ العمليه وفي الثاني
من اكتوبر من العام الجاري قتل جندي
اسرائيلي جراء اطلاق نار يستهدف مجموعه من
الجنود الاحتلال القربه المستوطنه اماره
واصيب سائق حافله بجروح استهدافها بعمليه
الاطلاق النار
وفي ثامن من اكتوبر من العام الجاري ايضا
قتلت قتلت مجنده واصيب حارس امن جر عمليه
اطلاق النار التي نفذها عدي التميمي على
حاجز شعفاط في القدس المحتله وفي الخامس
عشر من نوفمبر 20 الثاني من العام الجاري
قتل ثلاثه مستوطنين اصيب اربعه اخرون
بجروح خطيره اثر عمليه طعن في ثلاثه مواقع
في مستوطنه ال شمال الضفه الغربيه